el grupo talibán sigue su avance
implacable en afganistán en poco más de
una semana los insurgentes han tomado el
control de 20 de las 34 capitales
provinciales del país ya arana qalat y
asadabad fueron las últimas en caer y la
estratégica yalalabad está en serio
riesgo aumentando el cerco sobre kabul
con este panorama el presidente afgano
ahmad dhani ordenó reorganizar las
fuerzas de seguridad para enfrentar la
ofensiva talibán usen iguales ya que en
la situación actual la removilización de
las fuerzas de seguridad y defensa es
nuestra máxima prioridad y se están
tomando las medidas necesarias para este
propósito tal acción y conan conax ahora
haré todo lo posible para evitar que
esta guerra impuesta al pueblo afgano
resulte más asesinatos de gente inocente
la pérdida de nuestros logros de los
últimos 20 años la destrucción de
infraestructura y una inestabilidad
prolongada web y subotic wonder ser el
mandatario sostuvo que está en consultas
con líderes locales e internacionales
para frenar la violencia y prometió dar
a conocer resultados pronto pero estos
mensajes no calman la inquietud de
varios residentes que intentan salir del
país
del aeropuerto
los combates se están volviendo peor
cada día y la oposición está avanzando
solía trabajar con extranjeros y no
estoy a salvo cada día tenía el estrés
de no saber qué podía pasar conmigo
cuánto tiempo debemos vivir luchando
tiene que haber alguna solución para que
la gente pueda vivir en un ambiente
pacífico en este país
mientras tanto ciudades como eran
retoman su actividad bajo el régimen
talibán
y países como pakistán o turquía
refuerzan sus fronteras ante la llegada
de desplazados afganos a la par crece el
temor a la xenofobia contra estas
personas